hi amanda
hi how you guys doing
so here you are you are free from jail
yeah three months yeah it's been three
months now you're
in a rehab yeah kind of on the outskirts
of l.a
yeah fair amount and how are you liking
it so far
it's okay i eat cravings a lot cravings
for crack
yeah yeah i'm sure it's not easy how's
it how's it going
it's okay sometimes i feel like leaving
but
i gotta stick it through i gotta stay
strong yeah basically
you're building a new life yeah yeah and
the life you had was so dangerous and so
destructive yeah and you were going to
end up dead
you you know that right yeah so
what's going on in your life in the last
three months i think is perhaps the
the the way to get out of this yeah
the jail helped and that that must have
been difficult to not have anything
not have the drugs that you wanted and
not have the freedom that you were used
to
yeah was jail awful yeah i was awful
i was always hungry i gained like 30
pounds
yeah i mean crack is a good diet yeah
so i mean you were you were this is
about the weight you were
at before right before you started using
crack no you were you were lighter
smaller definitely well you were okay
yeah i didn't know
that i was way smaller before i went to
jail well you're going through lots of
adjustments now
yeah lots of hopefully i can lose the
weight
yeah i'm sure you can yeah just you know
you you have a new
you have new everything right now yeah
routine new life new
new new are you making friends here yeah
there's some nice people i mean it's
very small rehab yeah it's a really
small rehab it's only five people it's
only four people here
it's very luxurious including me yeah
it's real nice
to mention so you have to be here how
about like a year right
and six months yeah but i think a year
total just before you
you have to be clean i guess for a year
before you'll be free from the
risk of going back to jail yeah
so what are what are your thoughts now
what do what are you nothing i'm just
staying strong i'm counting my days
i want to be able to be clean when i
leave
yeah that's that would i think i mean
everybody wants that lima wants it your
dad wants it your family
i'd love it the viewers would love it
but you need to want it too
yeah i think that's going to be the key
yeah
and you've even you've also been taking
all kinds of crazy medications that
probably screwed with your diet as well
yeah the medicine made me gain weight
yeah i was taking
what they were giving you in jail yeah
yeah so you're off that now
yeah i want that and you're doing
therapy here as well
yeah her name's um her name susan
my therapist yeah i think that would be
a great thing for you to do some therapy
and
work out whatever got you into the
situation in the first place
yeah but you know i think you know we
never talked about your mom but your mom
is
was never really in your life right yeah
it was hard not having a mom
that would be awful yeah that's going to
be a big deal for you i cried a lot over
she did my hair once when i was 13 but i
never seen her
she's a beautician she was a crackhead
too yeah but i never knew her
she's still alive but yeah she's still
alive she's never been in your life
yeah so that's a that's i'm sure therapy
will explore that
yeah we talked about it a little bit
yeah
yeah it's frustrating not having her in
my life
yeah that'd be hard for anybody yeah
and you're getting your teeth fixed next
week right yeah
i have a dental appointment and get my
teeth sick
get some new teeth so how'd you lose a
teeth your dad and i were talking about
it over here
i don't remember what he said blacked
out you got in a fight with somebody and
they knocked your teeth out
yeah you hit the street or something
like that
do you have any moments where you're
thinking that you want to go back to
that life
yeah all the time it's okay yeah i'm
trying to stay strong though
good for you yeah it's got to be very i
mean
i think crack is probably one of the
hardest drugs to break free from yeah
and you've been you've been clean for
three months now yeah
and i think the longer you go and the
more you go through therapy and the more
you get used to this new routine
the better your chances will be yeah i
gotta stay sober
yeah you're such a beautiful girl it'd
be so great to see you thank you
away from that that terrible life yeah
it's such a destructive lifestyle yeah
and you you know you're gonna end up
you were asking you're trying to kill
yourself basically
do you have any any anything you'd like
to do with your life you're still young
how old are you you're 20
i'm 25. you're 25. yeah you're older
than i thought
um what uh what would you like to do do
you have any ideas
maybe like a program where i can get a
certificate
become a technician
what kind of technician like medical
dental medical
medical yeah that'd be great you were
going to school for something
yeah i just did my basics so i went to
school
i didn't make friends because i was
always under my boyfriend
he used to walk me to class he didn't go
there
he was just we were just always up under
each other so i never made friends in
college i didn't have the college
experience
how did you how did you get introduced
to craft do you remember
yeah it started with primo primo
cigarettes
and then it leads to crack reals are pot
with
lace with the crack right yeah and did
you
did your boyfriend at the time no we
were broken out
that's why i became a prostitute that's
when i came across too when we broke up
i was like 22. and and how did
prostitution come into the picture
not having money for the drug oh i see
yeah yeah
that'll do it yeah
so what is your your new routine here
like i see you have a beautiful kitchen
yeah we do chores in the morning and
there's a pool in the back yeah i've
been in jacuzzi a couple of times it was
cool
but nothing nothing as good as crack
i gotta say strong though good for you
it's good it's good that you can talk
about it though and admit that that's a
temptation for you yeah
yeah when how is it when is it hardest
in the morning at night when you're
tired at night because i can't go to
sleep because then my lifestyle was
always up
i didn't even sleep in jail you didn't
sleep and you were in jail
no because i was always up 24 7
in my in my lifestyle so it was hard
going to sleep it's hard going to sleep
what was the hardest part of
getting getting off of it the first week
or the first month
yeah the first month first month was
hard yeah
is it getting easier no
no it's not getting easier it's wet
it's not getting easier it's not getting
easier no
wow it's real hard on me
i crazy drag like 24 7.
yeah and looking back now do you
do you regret ever getting involved in
that in the first place no
you don't you don't regret it no
really yeah i'm gonna be honest wow
yeah it's real hard on me being here
do you think if you if you somehow got
out of here you'd run back to downtown
and
back to skid row no you would you you
you would
you don't think that there's a risk of
that yeah good for you
yeah good for you well i hope you uh
hope you can ride this out
all right and i think the longer you do
it the better the easier it'll get
yeah because there is a whole world out
there of
wonderful people and wonderful things
and
you know wonderful things you can do and
you know find something that
makes you happy and man i'd love to see
you get uh
get away from that and never go back
yeah let me look at your mom
so your mom was was using crack and
probably still is yeah
so that's that's your fate perhaps if
you don't do
take advantage of this this opportunity
yeah
what do you think of lima rima is good i
love her
she's real pretty pretty yeah but she's
doing a really nice thing for you too
yeah and your dad is supporting you 100
and your family back in texas
i definitely need support are you
getting letters from some of the uh
the viewers yeah i got a couple of cards
thank you guys
yeah yeah i think there's a lot of
people that would love to see you turn
the corner on this
yeah well all right
all right well i'll come back many times
and we'll do many of these and get
updates and see how you're going
all right and you can say hi to
everybody and show them hi everybody
thank you so much for your support
all right amanda thank you so much
you